good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is learn to say no over to you Maya
Angelou there's a place in you that you
must keep inviolate you must keep it
pristine clean so that nobody has a
right to curse you up treat you badly
nobody no mother father no wife no
husband knows nobody because that may be
the place you go to when you meet God
you have to have a place but they just
say stop it back up not he must not know
no absolutely and that's one I told you
25 years ago
yes say no when it's no yeah say so back
it up because that place has to remain
clean and clear and that has to be a
place within you yes ma'am yeah in order
to know when to say no you have to know
what you're saying for it's why I wrote
this book to figure out what your most
important core value is your one word
that's what you stand for and therefore
you know what you stand against to know
how to say no and when to say no you
have to know this is not what I'm about
I'm not willing to touch this I'm not
willing to go there and if you don't
know what you stand for and you don't
know what you stand against then you're
always gonna be subject to other
people's opinions other people's plans
are the people's values and beliefs
because if you have uncertainty if you
don't have clarity over what your values
are then you'll just follow somebody
else's values and that's very rarely in
your best interest and so getting really
clear on what your values are whether
you want to use the one word methodology
or you have a different plan for
yourself that's fine but having a
self-awareness to figure out this is
what I stand for this is what I want out
of life and this is also what I am no
longer
willing to accept when people cross
these boundaries I'm not going to play
anymore I'm gonna say no until you
understand what your values are then it
can be really tricky to understand the
difference between what is your value
and what is it limited belief so as an
example was on a call with an
entrepreneur a couple days ago and he
was struggling at his business and he
was working for a client and the client
was asking him to get more involved in
their business to do more work with them
and he was having a hard time figuring
out whether he should do it or not and
it's two reasons why one is because they
were kind of shady and he wasn't sure
how much you know in bed he wanted to
get with them and two because they were
asking him to take on more of a
leadership role and to manage people and
he wasn't sure that he wanted to be a
leader he didn't know if he was good
enough to be a leader those are two
totally different processes that you
need to break up right so if they are
shady that's against your core value
like if you know what your core value is
and then these people are against it
then no matter how much they're paying
you or you know what they want to push
you through or even the good that
they're necessarily doing it's not worth
it because asking to cross the line that
you're not willing to cross you know my
one word is believe if you want me to do
something that's gonna tear somebody
else down and you're gonna pay me a
million dollars to do it I don't want to
do it because it's against my core value
it's easier to say no it's and it
becomes hard to say no and there's a lot
of money being thrown at you right the
devil always comes carrying a bag of
cash so to know that this is where I'm
gonna say no one draw the line because I
know what I stand for so working with a
shady company is a reason to say no
potentially the other side is the
leadership he hasn't done leadership
before he hasn't managed a team before
he hasn't been involved in that process
before and he's scared that is a
limiting belief that's not necessarily a
value thing it's a limiting belief
feeling like you're not good enough
pushing yourself to get on your comfort
zone and try doing something new a car
in a new skill that you're afraid of
potentially acquiring right jump into
that next level so there's a lot of
different reasons to say no here I'd be
able to separate them if you're saying
no because they're a shady organization
then great
then say no because you're staying firm
on your values if you're saying no
because they want you to be a leader and
you're just afraid because you haven't
done that before and you feel like
you're not good enough that's not a good
reason to say no that's a living to
believe that is worth you testing out
try it and see if you're a good leader
right and if you get into it and you
really feel like this isn't for you then
you found that out but to make an
assumption about something you haven't
tried before it's gonna hold you back
and so until you understand what it is
that you stand for and then stand
against it's going to be hard to make
the important decisions in your life
it's going to be hard to say no when you
really should be saying no it's gonna be
hard to say yes to something when
everything inside you is just afraid
because it's a limiting belief but you
really should do it to push your comfort
zone and get to that next place for
yourself and so comes down to the
self-awareness but you know what you're
staying for you know what you send
against you figure out your value system
you figure out your one word the path
forward becomes so much more clear that
you can go so much faster it's so much
more done because you're following a
path that you're meant to follow so the
question today today is I'm curious do
you guys know you're one word I don't
think I've asked you that in a while I'd
love to hear from you share it down the
comments below really curious to find
out I also want to give a quick charter
to Becky sisa thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go
it's 8:00 a.m. like I gotta get to the
office and I was like why like why do I
have to get like I I always wanted to be
a writer I accomplished this thing I
could make a living being a writer I
have a home like I haven't been there in
weeks like why am I here and and I was
like I was here because like I just said
yes and I didn't think about like I
didn't I didn't actually weigh like the
pros and cons of this scenario and again
it's like sometimes you got to do it you
don't want to do to figure out what you
want to do but it was like I I'd sort of
distanced myself from a lot of things
and I've gotten got in my life in a good
place and then someone called me and
offered me money on the phone and I said
yes because it's so hard to say it like
it's so hard to to say no to stuff like
especially if you're like I do it's so
hard to say like I want to do this but I
also want to do that I have to choose
it's easy to say like I'm gonna try to
do both at the same time and I said yes
to both like I don't I don't think I've
ever like quit anything like I've just
added new stuff right and so for me that
certainly has added up over time to an
unsustainable load oh I'm great at
boundaries I'm not great at boundary so
I'm kidding I so thought that was gonna
be a laugh line I thought you guys knew
me I thought you knew me well enough to
know that um no I I don't have any
better I'm the permeable membrane I
don't know I let I let the you know I am
a little better at it but but I have I
don't know I have learned one important
thing which is that I think you sort of
get to a point in your life where you
think I have to learn how to say no to
things I don't want to do and that's a
big mature moment when you start to
begin to do that but the bigger mature
moment is when you learn how to say no
to things you do want to do because you
know that you just don't have time or
you don't have energy or there just
isn't you know you have to sort of
triage your life and there just isn't an
opportunity and and that only came to me
various
that sometimes you you have to turn down
even the wonderful things in order to
take care of your health or to take care
of what you truly truly truly care about
not just what you truly care about how
can you find the time the energy the
effort and the nerve to start to make
that first call to put out that first
bandit sign to put up a Craigslist they
have to start 225 to one to call banks
how do you do that well this one today
is learning to say no now one thing I've
learned from the most successful people
on the planet if you want to say
millionaires I've been lucky enough to
meet billionaires the one thing I've
learned the more they say no the
wealthier they get now you may have
heard me say this before but it's that
important of a success principle it took
you a lot of yeses to get here yes the
over time yes to missing your kids you
know soccer or dance class yes to your
wife your husband getting upset because
you're working later yes to getting my
program yes to go into a live event yes
to getting the education yes yes yes yes
to your friends you know you if you're
watching this you are the busiest people
other people no they say if you want
something done ask somebody busy because
they know how to get things done that's
you you're the person in your family
amongst your friends I know it or else
you wouldn't be watching me they could
ask for emotional support financial
support for a ride for help for advice
so you are used to saying yes so this
week I want you to say no I want you to
make a list of the things that you must
say no to so you can focus on you so you
can make a massive impact for your
family you want to help family members
that need money say no to them for a
year becoming an incredible real estate
investor and then if you want to cut
them checks you can if you want to give
more to your church you want to give
more to charity say no for a little
while to so many things so your brains
not all over the place we think we have
a DD most of us don't have a DD there's
just too much coming at us and we say
yes to too many things so here's the
assignment what can you figure out to
say no to this week because if you say
no to things that don't improve your
life don't improve your family's life
don't possibly increase your future
income or put you on a path to the goals
that you have to spend more time with
your family to get out of a job you hate
to pay off bills I don't know what they
are but you have
make a not a to-do list but you have to
make a list of what not to do who are
you gonna say no to who are you gonna
disappoint what are you gonna let go
what habits are eating up your time yeah
the most important word ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details